IT'S NOW TIME TO PLAY
PERFORMANSHART.
I MEAN...
WHATEVER, ART'S OKAY, I GUESS.
IT'S USUALLY THE ARTISTS THAT
SUCK, AND YOU CAN TAKE THAT TO
THE BANKSY.
SO I'M GONNA GIVE YOU SOME CLIPS
OF PERFORMANCE ARTISTS AND FOR
250 POINTS I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
GIVE ME A TITLE FOR THEIR WEIRD
ART PIECE.
FIRST ONE, THIS HAPPY COUPLE.
>> (BOTH VOCALIZING)
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: AISHA.
>> AND THEY NEVER [BLEEP]ED
AGAIN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS, POINTS.
CHRIS.
>> WOMEN.
AM I RIGHT?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, THIS JAPANESE
LATE-FOR-WORK ROBOT.
(BELL DINGS)
JAPAN, WHY DO YOU KEEP DOING
THESE AWFUL THINGS?
YOU HURT ME.
CHRIS.
>> UPSKIRT CHARLIE.
>> HARDWICK: JUDY.
>> UM, THE LITTLE ASIAN THAT
COULD.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
EXCELLENT.
NEXT ONE, THIS COURTNEY LOVER.
>> (GRUNTING)
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: AISHA.
>> THAT IS THE LAST TIME I LET
YOU [BLEEP] IN MY HAIR.
NEVER AGAIN.
>> HARDWICK: JUDY.
>> UM, WE'LL JUST TAKE THE
CHECK.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
NEXT ONE -- THIS GUY'S
BEEN LIVING IN A BEAR CARCASS
FOR 13 DAYS AND HIS LOCAL NEWS
STATION IS ALL OVER THE STORY.
>> THE LATEST WORK OF ABRAHAM
POINCHEVAL, A FRENCH PERFORMANCE
ARTIST, INVOLVES HIM LIVING
INSIDE OF A BEAR CARCASS FOR 13
DAYS.
>> HARDWICK: OH, JESUS CHRIST.
(BELL DINGS)
UH... AISHA.
>> MAN, BROOKLYN IS REALLY
STARTING TO SUCK.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
YUP.
CHRIS.
>> UH, FRENCHY WASTES HIS TRUST
FUND.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK (FRENCH ACCENT): I
DIDN'T KNOW-- I THOUGHT IT WAS
THE OTHER KIND OF BEAR.
ALL RIGHT, LAST ONE, THIS
OFF-DUTY WET NURSE.
♪ ♪
>> YEAH.
THIS IS THE WORST.
>> I HATE HER.
>> AND I FEEL LIKE I KNOW HER.
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: CHRIS.
>> LOOK AT ME, I'M WASTING MILK.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.
JUDY.
>> AMERICAN APPAREL'S SUMMER
CATALOG.
>> HARDWICK: THAT'S GENIUS.
POINTS.